[Music]
[Applause]
why would I ever hire you
Oh over one of the finance majors
sitting outside of my office I took a
deep breath my heart rate soaring and I
blurted out because you can train any
monkey in a soup to run a financial
model I never forgot that interview
question but I do wish that I had a
second chance to answer it and let me
tell you I would answer it
very differently today I want to talk to
you about why hiring musicians and
artists can strengthen businesses and
teams my focus will be on music given
the influence its had on my life and my
hope is the next time you see a
non-traditional resume instead of
putting it in the reject pile you'll
move it to the top of your consideration
set music has been a part of my life
before I was even born my parents named
me after hearing pianist Eliseo della
Rocha perform and I was an adamant a
covenant my Kincaid isolate age of 8 I
picked up a tiny toy size violin and I
squished squeaked out my first attempt
of twinkle twinkle little did I know to
see hours of isolated practicing the
heated arguments with my brother over
how to play a phrase of Mendelssohn or
my realized dream of performing under
the bright lights of Carnegie Hall would
actually prepare me for careers in
business
your abstract and orchestra carries a
striking resemblance to a business you
have strings winds and the brass
consider these similar to sales finance
and HR each specialty has its own skill
set personality and unique function yet
all of them all just as the divisions of
a company unique skill set yet all the
instruments need to work seamlessly
together in order to perform a dazzling
Brahms Symphony just as the divisions of
a company need to collaborate seamlessly
in order to run a business an orchestra
when the time comes the cacophony of
last-minute tuning and practicing
subsides the conductor raises his arms
and the musicians take the stage to
unveil some of the most powerful
representations of teamwork and high
performance and it's in this Orchestra
where I learned some really valuable
lessons that I still turn to today so
let's look at five common interview
questions and how a musician might
answer them
question one tell me about a time you've
managed conflict I'm a violinist and
violinists are the Divas of the
orchestra
we're opinionated we're competitive and
we all want to play the solos so you can
imagine the first time I was tasked to
lead an all violin practice session
where we had to agree on how we wanted
to play our part there were more
opinions in that room than there were
people so how do I get this group of
prima donnas to agree I suggested that
we demonstrate our ideas through playing
and pretty quickly we found that certain
phrasing and styles were better than
others and we were able to agree on a
vision that we were eager to execute and
bring back to our orchestral team
question two how do you build
credibility on a team my friend Sam is
an accomplished organist who won a
scholarship to a prestigious university
to pursue conducting and later moved on
to a career in business in government
life takes Sam far from the organ and
podium today
but he fondly recalls learning about
accountability and its importance went
on a team through his musical training
he asked me to imagine walking into a
room with a million items on my to-do
list but the manager needs me in that
room the meeting starts and it's
immediately clear there's no agenda no
goals no paths for discussion how many
of you have been in a meeting like this
they're frustrating they're discouraging
and they make us lose faith in the
person who called it Sam likens the
familiar scenario to his work as a
conductor his ability to lead and
influence a choir hinged on
demonstrating his respect for their time
through preparation and ownership of his
artistic responsibilities now as a
manager Sam is able to more easily
establish accountability on teams and
acknowledge when he's losing trust among
them and rectify that situation quickly
question three tell me about a skill
you've had to learn over time musicians
have resilience diligence and grit the
orchestra isn't just about the conductor
or the concert master just as a business
isn't only about senior level management
each individual in the orchestra has
spent years developing their craft in
order to play their assigned part Joel
Peterson the chairman of JetBlue Airways
and a professor here at the Graduate
School of Business had all of his
children get involved in music because
in his words there's no way to cram all
the smart kids in school will always
inevitably find a shortcut or a way
around the system but he believes you
can't do that with music music requires
putting in the time the hard work and
the discipline in order to improve your
performance and this ability to develop
resilience a work ethic and a sense of
one's self becomes increasingly
important as a career growth question
for what would you do in a situation
where you have multiple tasks to
complete but no conceivable way of
finishing them all by the deadline
musicians frequently become great
practitioners of the 80
a principle that ability to identify
where the most value might come from I
prioritize certain actions over others
Bess a former consultant and now a
founder of her own successful venture
told me that she hated practicing the
violin the hours spent alone in a room
knowing that she was not spending time
with friends or other fun activities
made her resent practicing so what was
the solution quickly identify the most
important or difficult passages and
focus on mastering those first Elvis
didn't mean that putting in hours didn't
matter but she was able to learn how to
use her time more effectively now by the
time that she got her first job
Bess was able to identify the more
valuable parts of a project faster than
her peers and she was a better
contributor and teammate because of it
question five how would your boss or
your coworkers describe you from an
early age musician's experience coaching
at a forensic level I vividly remember
peering over my violin teachers shoulder
to better understand how to hold my bow
or play a finger twisting passage of
Bach this ability to be coached is
something we aspire to as business
leaders we seek feedback and we hope to
monitor ourselves when there's no coach
around us with the musicians receiving
feedback doesn't need to be taught
because the concept is already ingrained
just as a conductor might make a minor
adjustment to better tease out a melody
musicians are ready to hear from their
managers or mentors on how to present
more effectively tweaks a financial
model or more meaningfully interact with
their peers so when we return to the
orchestra as a whole it's a really
powerful training ground for teamwork
influence and leadership all at the same
time even with the conductor at the helm
the whole is undoubtedly greater than
the sum of the parts a successful
performance depends on knowing who's
playing what role around you and being
able to anticipate the actions of others
to quote dr. Condoleezza Rice the
former Secretary of State professor at
Stanford and a highly accomplished
classical pianist musicians need to let
their creativity humanity and
vulnerability come through despite all
the hours invested in their craft
anything can happen when you're onstage
and you have to push through and learn
from your mistakes
even today I know I found the ability to
stand in front of you because of years
of experience performing under bright
lights and in front of huge crowds so if
I could rewind that clock I walk once
again down the hall of that investment
bank I would stand a little taller as I
walk past the other typical interviewees
I would feel more comfortable in my
first suit I would know why my resume
was at the top of the pile why should
you hire me over the others in the hall
because I manage conflict
I value accountability I work tirelessly
at my craft I'm coachable but most
importantly because I am a musician
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]